le premier combat ça a été un de
survivre aux flammes et le deuxième ça a
été de me reconstruire simplement
[Musique]
dans ma situation le plus difficile ça a
été et c'est encore le regard des gens
on
quand je me suis regardé dans la glace
je me suis vu déjà shove non pas parce
que mais je fais avait pris feu mais
parce qu'en fait il avait dû me raser la
tête
volontairement pour prendre de la peau
de la peau saine pour pouvoir faire des
greffes de peau je me suis vu maigre
d'un mec parce que j'avais passé trois
mois dans le coma et que je pouvais pas
manger j'étais clairement alité et les
cicatrices était rouge et pour souffler
parce qu'elle venait d'être fait et
voilà
[Musique]
ce qui m'aide en postant ses photos
c'est clairement le retour que j'en ai
les commentaires ultra positif les
messages privés les attentions
toute cette vague de positivité ça m'a
juste donné envie de continuer je me
suis dit finalement les gens ça ne les
choque pas donc je peux y aller quoi y
aller mais ce qui était super étrange
c'est que je m'autorisais ça sur
instagram mais pas dans la vie de tous
les jours j'ai fait ça à la base pour
que
pour qu'on m'aide c'était un peu un
appel au secours on appelle à l'aide
une demande de réconfort et un jour la
tendance s'est inversée j'ai commencé à
recevoir des messages de femmes
atteintes de cancer de jeune fille
brûlée d'hommes brûlé d'hommes
handicapés de femmes enceintes avec des
vergetures y est tous ces messages qui
me disaient mais julie merci de partager
mon histoire parce que quotidiennement
tu te rend peut-être pas compte mais moi
tu m'aides et grâce à toi je vais
peut-être rose et un t-shirt gt3 et un
maillot de bain et là je me suis dit
waouh en fait le message que je suis en
train de transmettre sa du poids ça de
l'importance et ça peut aller encore
plus loin que ce que j'imaginais quoi
[Musique]
en soit brûlé pour sa petite conçoit
ronde pour soit maigre on reste une
femme et c'est important de le montre
aujourd'hui dans une société où la femme
est souvent catégoriser par la femme
parfaite photoshopée
[Musique]